welcome back this is the ben shapiro
show we're taking your calls at
855-236-3228-236-3208 gabriel in florida
you're on the bench
go for gabriel um i just want to get
your opinion on how you think
with all this moving and uh and
everything going on how do you think
it's going to affect
the election and if trump does get
reelected how do you think it'll
escalate
um everything that's going on oh man
well i mean first of all i do think that
if trump is elected then this will get
significantly worse because the
blackmail
doesn't end just because trump gets
reelected and that the blackmail
increases because again
part of the agenda here is to
incentivize what democrats have called
quote unquote good trouble
and that's okay if you're talking about
you know pri protests or or sitting at a
lunch counter i mean that is
good trouble in the john lewis phrase
but they've failed to disambiguate it as
wesley yang points out
from actual acts of evil rioting and
looting and violence and they're
actively doing this they're actively
incentivizing this we've had
three full months of rioting and looting
in portland when they're allowing it
we've had rioting and looting in chicago
in l.a in new york in washington dc in
baltimore like literally every major
city in america
run by democrats has been racked by this
rioting and looting
and the explicit point of it for many of
the democrats is this is a result of all
of the anger stemming from american
systemic racism and evil
and the only way that we stop this
rioting and looting is if we stop the
systemic racism and the only person who
can do that is this octogenarian
buffoon who's been in congress for 50
years joe biden
and so if he isn't elected well then the
systemic racism hasn't been stopped
and therefore the violence has to
continue it's a blackmail scheme
everybody knows it's a blackmail scheme
um but that doesn't mean they're going
to stop the blackmail and it doesn't
mean that mayors are going to are going
to stop it which eventually will
necessitate
trump calling in the insurrection act
and stopping it himself i mean i i think
that if trump is re-elected i fully
predict that the violence will escalate
and
it won't just continue it'll escalate
fairly dramatically and trump's going to
have to call in
federal forces in order to put it down
the insurrection act will be invoked
because american citizens still have
rights and they have a right
to have their property and lives
protected even if the local authorities
would prefer to allow violence and
looting to be used as a political tool
against republicans and against the
president politically so i think that is
most likely by the way the writing and
the looting are cutting against the
democrats it's why you're seeing
democrats starting to casual
to softly move away from the writing and
well it's unnecessary it's bad guys we
don't really like it so much
we really have to solve the underlying
issues of course but it's really it's
really kind of like
not nice unnecessary counterproductive
unuseful
not even not morally evil which it is
but but all these other things so
democrats are recognizing the polls are
cutting against them now
particularly in swing states like trump
i would say is probably now going to win
wisconsin if this continues in any way
shape or form
uh i think that trump has a serious shot
at minnesota now because of what's been
happening in minneapolis
i mean he's running pretty close to even
in minnesota as well
i think you're going to see the pulse
titan in florida i think you're going to
see the pulse titan in michigan i think
you're going to see the pulse titan in
pennsylvania
all trump has to do is shut his face and
let the democrats continue to make the
case that they would love to see the
country blackmailed into voting democrat
gabriel
yeah i agree with you completely on that
and i do see that it's now starting to
uh
basically bite the democrats in the ass
uh because people are starting to
realize that this is ridiculous and
unprecedented
and now my other question for you would
be now what do you think
how do you think this would play out if
joe biden won what is his magical plan
to magically stop all the racism and
violence and moving across the cities
so if joe biden wins i think that what
you will see is a
softening of the violence maybe some of
the mayors crack down a little bit
specifically in order to
make clear that the black male threat
was good right that it they would
continue the violence
unless republicans lost office so i
would expect to see that the violence is
quashed pretty quickly
you see this whenever democrats actually
get threatened right mayor jenny durkin
the terrible mayor of seattle
she was perfectly fine with an entire
fake tyrannical republic set up in the
middle of her city up until the point
where they marched outside her house and
then she was like send in the forces
stop this crap now
so the the democrats will start to
do agenda items of the rioters and
looters and claim that they have
channeled all that energy all that you
know overzealous but but good energy
into legislation and then when they lose
next time then there will be more
riots and looting presumably i
appreciate the call gabriel
kyle in palm springs you're on the bench
for you should go for a kyle
uh i i consider myself more of a uh
essentialist
so uh it's kind of difficult for me to
voice my opinion at times because i'm
kind of you know mix and match between
the two
um how do i voice an opinion without
being called
without being labeled something that i'm
clearly not
well i mean again my common response to
this is
that it is very important that if
somebody labels you a racist without
evidence you call them a jackass and
walk away
i think it's actually very important
because that's a character attack it's
not a political argument
simply labeling somebody's character
based on policies you disagree with
as opposed to arguing with the policies
is the mark of intellectual
stuntedness and and you you shouldn't
stand for it you shouldn't pretend that
the person has
a leg to stand on and you shouldn't
morally justify being in an argument
with somebody
of that ilk so that yeah i think that it
is a mistake
uh to to even entertain the argument
that you're a racist if they can provide
no evidence that you're actually a
racist kyle
appreciate the call carson in new york
you're on the bench i'll go for it
carson
hey of course hey hey ben um i just
wanted to ask like what is your uh
stance on athletes
what is what are athlete roles to you in
terms of society because i've noticed
that you've
you're not exactly a fan of athletes or
other people that are celebrities
speaking up for causes
and i thought that as a conservative you
would
um be fine with people basically using
their platform
um to speak up for causes they believe
in because
the things that conservatives make the
point is is that regardless of your
income level
um that shouldn't preclude you from you
know investing in politics so i just
wanted your perspective on it yeah so
carson first of all you have every right
to say what you want and i've said this
repeatedly about lebron james i've
literally said on my show repeatedly
that i'm i'm not saying shut up and
dribble i'm saying he can say whatever
he wants it doesn't mean he knows what
the hell he's talking about
and i think that just because athletes
and celebrities say things that doesn't
mean that we should take them seriously
i also think that it is terrible
business to take
what is an apolitical job namely being
an athlete
and then to slather the actual product
in politics so if i were an athlete and
i want to speak out politically i would
save that for the microphone after the
game
i wouldn't be injecting it into the
actual product that people want to watch
because now
you've changed the quality of the
product i mean people are tuning into
basketball not to watch politics
if you want to tune in after the game
and watch lebron talk politics or you
want to watch lebron do an interview
with the new yorker
you are perfectly free to do so i just
think it's bad business i think it's
idiotic that the owners have allowed
this sort of thing to take over the
actual product being fielded
i think it's true in the nfl i think
it's idiotic and mlb i think it's stupid
in the nba
and again my view on athletes and
anybody look it's a free country you're
free to speak out however you want
doesn't mean i have to pretend that i
think you know what you're talking about
or that you have been conferred any sort
of expertise by the fact that you're
rich and famous in a field that is not
this one
yeah but do do you appreciate the fact
though that like there's
you know especially as we see like the
riots they're speaking in like a
peaceful way
and they're the people with the biggest
voice i'm not seeing
honestly i'm not seeing a lot of
condemnation of the violence and looting
i'm not saying a ton of it i'm seeing a
lot of america systemically racist
and systemically evil and the jacob
blake officer should be arrested and the
brianna taylor officer should be
arrested and the fact that they have not
been arrested is evidence that america's
systemically racist and evil
if every single one of these celebrities
in the nba
came out and said rioting and looting
are evil you should not do them they are
evil
then i would have a lot more respect for
the position that they're taking but
but frankly i don't think that you know
we should be listening to athletes on
politics generally anyway they don't
have any
you shouldn't listen to me about how to
plan a triangle offense and you probably
shouldn't listen to lebron james about
how to plan
a a piece of police reform legislation
is that is that fair i'm not i'm not i'm
not an expert on his own defense
i don't think lebron james is an expert
on the history of policing
in the united states let alone the the
current state of policing in the united
states
matthew new jersey you're on the bench
spiritual fort matthew i wanted to ask
sorry i wanted to ask you about the
prospect of america splitting up by the
year 2033
um due to the violence and the
escalation
i i've had this thought for
about eight to ten years and i'm seeing
it come to fruition in certain ways
i wanted to know your thoughts on that
yep uh
i think that you know the possibility of
the country drifting further apart is is
pretty obvious
and particularly if if democrats get
away with
overriding all institutional boundaries
and one of the things that the founders
basically instituted
was a system where broad change in the
united states would have to require
broad approval this is why you have
checks and balances and federalism and
and the filibuster democrats want to do
away with all of that and just allow 51
votes to basically trump everything else
as long as they have 51 votes in the
senate they can do whatever they want
that's going to exacerbate a lot of
these divides
the possibility of of states basically
breaking away from the feds
and then the fed saying okay well we
have still passed a federal law
and the state saying we'll go ahead and
try and enforce it uh i think that's
growing day by day
and i don't know what initiates this but
it seems like it's growing closer if
there comes a point
i've thought for a long time that it's
going to come on a freedom of religion
issue because there are certain things
that people are willing to pick up
weapons for in certain things that
people
are not it's going to be very difficult
to get people to pick up weapons
over things like transgender bathrooms
uh can be difficult for people to pick
up weapons over
things like even cancel culture um but
if it comes to the point where the
federal government for example suggests
that you must teach your child that a
man is a woman and a woman is a man if
you don't do that
then we are going to then we are going
to call that child endangerment
right which is something that by the way
they've started to do in canada already
then things could get really ugly really
really quickly if they say okay as a
religious person you are not allowed to
enact your religion in your daily life
in any way i think religious people will
resist if
if the democrats take office and then
they push a large-scale gun confiscation
regime
things could get very ugly very quickly
so i i wish i knew
how things would progress from there but
i mean it seems like the country is
getting uglier and it's hard to see how
the de-escalation happens unless again
officials reinstitute
a government monopoly on the use of
force in local areas i mean we're
watching running riots in america's
major cities for months on end
i don't know how that ends i don't
especially because at a certain point
people are gonna get sick of it and
they're gonna pick up guns and they're
gonna say okay well you're not allowed
to burn my business and if you come here
i'm going to shoot you
and then that escalates things further
so i i wish i had a crystal ball matthew
i don't
yeah even though it sounds like i do my
book how to destroy america in three
easy steps is in fact a prophecy but
aside from that it's not specific enough
rest for us to act on so i can't tell
you which stocks to buy
or exactly how this is going to go all i
can see is things are not going to get
better in the near future matthew
why do you think it's going to be
primarily a religious
issue rather than people trying to
defend their family
um so the question is what people are
being forced to defend their family over
so if you're asking you know if they're
riots in the streets and you defend your
family
and then you get prosecuted i mean if
that becomes a major thing and that
becomes a state law versus federal law
issue that would be one thing but
if you're talking about states breaking
away from the federal government which
is really
what we were talking about here the
dissolution of the united states by
state
uh then then you know that you'd have to
talk about a federal policy coming into
conflict with the state policy
typically self-defense and the and the
implications
of self-defense in american law uh
though those happen at the state level
within states that is not a federal
versus state conflict appreciate the
call
say i'm in hong kong you're on the bench
bureau show sam how are you even able to
call from hong kong has the chinese
government not intercepted this call at
this point
they probably have just not not been
arrested yet
go for it i appreciate the call cool
yeah i was just wondering how do you
think
the blm protests that are currently
happening will affect
um their elections in the coming year
and also how do you think
the blm protests in the u.s compare with
the hong kong protests
so i i think the protests in hong kong
are for freedom and civil rights and i
think that the protests in the united
states have nothing to do with either
the protests in the united states are
simply an expression of large-scale
angst over
all of the issues in the united states
ranging from covet
to racial discontent they have no
explicit program
the process in hong kong are about we
would like our freedoms back please we'd
like for the chinese government to stop
violating basic freedoms like freedom of
speech
and the ability to associate and
economic freedom
like that they have a specific agenda
the hong kong protesters the protesters
in america don't have any specific
agenda other than america sucks
so it seems like they're almost in
direct opposition i mean there's a
reason that the hong kong protesters
are flying the american flag while the
amer while the blm protesters
are sometimes burning american flags uh
that seems
in direct contravention as far as how
blm will affect the election i think
it's going to be a
negative for the democrats i think
they've gone too far i think that they
greenlit
rioting looting and violence for months
on end and now they're trying to buy it
back a little bit i don't think it's
gonna work i think most americans feel
threatened by a democratic party that is
willing to wink and not at this sort of
stuff
and i think trump could have not asked
for a or a better for for a better
campaign platform than democrats burning
major cities
i see um but do you think that the blm
causing a general shift left or
maybe perhaps a more divided political
landscape in the us
might help some democrats so i think
they think it will i think they think
it'll drive out voter turnout
um but i i don't think it's likely to do
that there were riots in 2014
2015 in ferguson in baltimore and it
didn't help voter turnout in 2016 for
the old white lady hillary clinton
so i do not think that the blm energy
translates over into significant voting
effect
uh in in 2020 for joe biden and
again i think that it may be
significantly outweighed particularly
in key swing states so it's important to
note that it may drive up turnout in
like new york and la
although again democrats may have shot
themselves in the foot here democrats
have been saying you all need to do
mail-in voting
well what happens when the fact remains
the vast majority of americans vote on
the day of the election at polling
places
and democrats have told them that they
all ought to mail in their vote and
they've created some real pitfalls for
themselves here i don't think the blm is
going to be the key issue for democrats
if they try to make it the key issue i
think it's going to backfire on them
pretty substantially in largely white
rural
states like wisconsin and michigan and
pennsylvania and
ohio sam appreciate the call we'll take
more of your phone calls coming up at
855 236 32 28 that's 855
236 32 28 this is the ben shapiro show